for our series i on earth we have this
the u.n secretary general saying
humankind
is waging a war on nature antonio
guterres spoke to us
here at cbs this morning ahead of a
major address today that he's calling
the state of the planet and in a word
that state is
broken he says citing man-made global
warming he's hoping to push the world
toward a more ambitious program to
address it we spoke to him as part of
covering climate now
a collaboration of more than 400 news
outlets worldwide
dedicated to explaining the problem and
the dangers of a warmer earth
with our old familiar planet
increasingly gone
burned and battered melting in ways
we've never experienced before
nearly 200 countries struck a deal to at
least begin to address the problem
of global warming but while the paris
agreement was ushered in with cheers
five years later it has not yet resulted
in significant
change i would say the majority of the
countries
have not been able to fulfill their
commitments made in paris
which is why united nations secretary
general antonio gutierrez is now warning
that the world's failure to act with
urgency
is not only dangerous but suicidal there
is a growing conscience
that the way we are moving is a suicide
in relation to the future
and to our future generations so to take
your metaphor
the world is on the ledge and your job
is to convince the world to step
off of it rather than jump it is true
as we speak here today the united states
is the only country
to leave the paris agreement we are not
in it how important was it
for joe biden to have won the election
in 2020
i think that the fact that the incoming
administration has announced
that they will again join the paris
agreement and they will commit to net
zero emissions in 2050
is absolutely crucial to rescue the
planet i understand that uh in some
people in the united states there is
this idea
that what makes sense is to have a
policy
more inward looking it is my true belief
that we all need to be cosmopolitan
and it is together that we can rescue
our planet
and improve the living conditions of
everybody everywhere guterres has
science on his side as he lays out the
problem predicting a planet forever
marked by stronger storms
more frequent heat waves and longer
droughts if the global average
temperature rises by more than 1.5
degrees celsius
by the end of the century right now
we're headed for at least twice
that increase we are still in line with
an increase of temperature of three to
five degrees in the end of the century
that would be
absolutely devastating for the world
economy and for
human life so it's time for the war
between
humankind of nature to end why is
humankind
at war with nature well because the
logic
of the economic development for a long
time was a logic of exploitation of
everything of every resource available
without looking into the future without
looking into the limits
historically the bulk of the world's
energy has come from oil
gas and coal fuels that create
greenhouse gas emissions which warm the
planet
finding a way to lower those emissions
is the only way to stop
global warming the world's oil and gas
companies
have trillions of dollars of oil and gas
that they know about
that they're waiting to dig up and to
sell
who is going to pay those companies to
not dig it up and burn it
the value of companies in history
changes with the changing conditions of
the global economy
there was a cycle of oil as the key
engine
of the world economy that cycle is
finished so the value of oil and gas
companies will diminish as the value of
coal companies is already diminishing
so i'm totally convinced that inevitably
a lot of the oil
and gas that is today in the soil
will remain in the soil so
that last point is why president trump
would say that the paris agreement was a
job killer
and what's interesting about uh guterres
is he's acknowledging that yeah it's a
job killer if you work for an oil and
gas company
but it's a job creator on the other side
on the other hand and really importantly
he's calling in this speech he's going
to give today for a basic
income as he calls it to help bridge
people out of the old industry to
something new and that's a change
talking about the economic pain and
alleviating it is a key change over the
last five years
and most importantly climate change if
you don't address it is a job killer yes
it's an economic disaster that's why
it's so important that we're having the
conversation again
yes very important yep all right very
interesting tony thank you
and you can hear more of that
conversation gail on the cbs morning
podcast
earbuds it just gets better and better